yeah i think so
we're very happy to have uh sd carman
from tel aviv university
um giving the next talk it's about
uh proof for the seminar result of
kkl and also for other results but
also seminar by frigate and telegram and
uh this is a
studying new proof technique for for
these um
very fundamental results analysis of
brilliant function and uh
sd is a phd student and we already heard
about their exciting work on the fourier
entropy
conjecture and now we hear about their
other exciting work so i'm very looking
forward to the future to see
and what works by sd so okay thank you
thank you vishai and uh thank you shine
prasad for organizing this
workshop
i'm really excited to be here and to
feel that i'm in san francisco i put a
picture that molly contributed
to this presentation
um so okay i will talk about
the work or
that i wish i presented
this talk about kkl type
results and i will explain why
i i call all of them kkl type
and we use alternate proof for the kkl
and the other
[Music]
terrans i will show this in this talk
only the proof of the kkkl but same
techniques works also for the
fruitfulness theorem and the
telegrams in quality um
and this is joint rock with subash heart
guy kindler dorminter and
muri safwa so let's start i'm going to
turn off my camera and if
i need to open it back um feel free to
ask any question
and i guess that i would miss the
questions in the
q a so i'm sure you're about on it okay
thank you
um okay so
the um i will give a very brief and
short
introduction for the boolean function
analysis
in general and it might be
a little boring for the experts here
that should be short and you will get to
know with my notations
um i actually try to find the
the notations of analysis of brilliant
functions but it's turned
out that there is no uh
notation um every paper use an advantage
and
uh maybe ryan or donald a book is a
is what the annotations of the analysis
functions and
i try to stick to his notations but okay
so the boolean functions are functions
on the boolean hypercube
um they might be boolean valued or
just values form r we defined the
[Music]
the inner product as we
see every function as a vector
on two to the n values and then the
inner products is
fairly trivial and for in this
functions we have the um
the parity functions that are the
the set of interesting functions that
actually consist the
um the basis the autonomous basis of
this vector space of boolean functions
and and then we have
we can represent every function as a
linear
combination of those parity functions
this
is well known as fourier transformation
fourier transform
and uh and then we have the f
hat is the fourier coefficient for every
character which is the parity function
um which is and the way to
uh to calculate the fourier coefficient
is
the inner product between f and the
appropriate
parity function
so i'm sorry um
i'll talk a little about influences so
we have the
derivative uh functions for every
direction i
the ice derivative uh
the iceberg the partial derivative
is um just how much the
function change in the y direction for
every x
and for every input and we can see that
for
boolean valued functions the derivative
functions are
also uh very similar to boolean they
have
only three values minus one and one that
say
what is the direction the function role
and zero if it doesn't change
in this input and direction
and the fourier presentation is very
easy to calculate
from the definition and we can see that
this is the part of
f that that actually live on
on characters that contains i
for every eyes direction
so the inferences are defined to be
the um the l two squared norm
of the derivative function and
for boolean valued functions it's
actually
the probability
of the ice bit to change the value of
the function
for every for random input
for another functions which are not
boolean valued
it's measure how much expectedly
the the value of change the value of the
function change on the direction i
um we can see that if we if we think
about a boolean valid function and
we look at all the edges in direction i
this is a fraction of those edges that
change the
value and
we have the percival which is uh
the percent value quality that we use
not only here
but a lot which says that the
delta squared norm of the values is the
same as the sum norm of the
coefficients and then we have that the
ice influence is exactly the
weight of f that lies on characters
contain i like all the characters that
involve in the direction i
and another uh
interesting object that we'll look at
is the total influence which
measure uh it's defined to be the
summation of all the inferences and
actually what it measure is the
probability of an edge to be
influential in the in all over the cube
it's also known as the average
sensitivity
and so up to normalization this is the
probability of an
edge to be sensitive and again for
representation the
presentation of the total influence is
very easy to calculate it from the
definitions
and it's if we we think about
the fourier
representation of f the fourier
coefficient squared as a
probability probability space then
we get that this is also the
expected character size which we also
can call
as the expected degree
um which will talk about the
um the differences between the maximal
degree and the expected degree how
when we want to use each of them so this
was just a
brief um
introduction and now we'll continue with
another introduction
and we'll talk about the kkl type terms
so i have here the definitions of the
individual influence and the total
influence
um at least for boolean functions this
boolean valued functions which are we
ones that we are concerned with and
let's see so what is the kkl theorem
um the classic version of it says that
for any
boolean functions let's think about
balanced functions
uh then exist uh some variable with
high influence or a large uh
at least log n over n we know that the
trivial one
is that for at least boolean functions
the total influence
is at least one and then there
there exists at least one individual
influence
which is at least one over n
so the kcal is says actually that there
is
an individual influence with non-trivial
uh influence which is
a factor login and
and we we can see what
uh what's behind this kkk theorem
there is another version which is
dimension free
and it implies this
classic kkl immediately
it's sometimes easier to work with that
sometimes it's easier to
just we just need to prove it
in order to get the kcl so um
what it say that there is always exist
some large individual influence
how large it's larger than two to minus
the total influence
or the total influence normalized are
you voted here
what's mean that either the total
influence
is large let's see how it implies uh
the kel's classic ical so it's uh either
the total influence is
large which means that
we we a trivially large individual
influence at least one
and otherwise if the total influence is
small then
this bound give us uh individual
influence which is large
and actually it's much larger than the
login over n
um which we need
so okay so this is the kkkrm
and now we'll talk a little bit about
fruit water we'll see how it
generalizes the kkl and uh
we'll continue from there so just
uh i put here a reminder what is the kcl
we say that there is some
individual influence which is larger
than 2 to minus the total influence
and the frito truntateron what says
is that for every boolean function
f is close to
small junta how small to to the
influence
um so i i don't care about constants i
just omit them from
everywhere
[Music]
so how it generalizes the the kkl
and so let's see about the proof idea of
the fruit good quanta theorem it's
the first step is to choose all the
individual inferences that are large
and how large we know from the kkk term
that there
exists at least one variable with
significant
individual influence so let's take all
of them
all of the large influences and what the
proof actually show
is that the part of f that
lies on characters
that involved only with variables with
i influence
takes almost all the the rate of the
function
and therefore this can be the junta and
there are not a lot of them because
they are large um
so what showed that that all the
the rate outside j
on of every character that involved on
non-influential
variable uh is negligible which means
that we just can drop
all the characters
with any non-influential variable and
still the function is very similar to
what we begin
begin with um
[Music]
so it's pretty clear how to generalize
the kkl
just for formalization we'll say it so
the kcl sure that
there is at least one significant
influence and the freedom
to say that most of the rate is actually
concentrated
on the significant influences
um so what about tolerance inequality
this is a
generalized generalization of the kkl um
very immediate and so it says that
every boolean function
the target sum which we have in the
right hand side
is uh is is bounded from below by the
variance and
if we think about a
balanced function this is actually some
constant
so um
when then talked about it last week and
say that
each cement here is uh somehow
represents the variance in direction i
i just take it as as it is you don't
really understand what's mean
but uh this is some meaning of this
and but you see that it somehow
says something about the um
probability
of the influences if we choose
variable according to its influence
so it's in vlog involved it's not
exactly the entropy
but somehow we have here the
log one over the influence so somehow we
can connect it to the entropy
um of the influences distribution
but let's see how it's uh generalized
the kkl so just take
the maximal influence in the
log term and we actually get exactly the
kkl you can rearrange the the inequality
and we get kkl
so um we have these three
arms actually the telegram and freed
woods and kcl
is inside them um
and of them are not they're not new
um so let's talk a little bit
from when they come so the original
proof for kkkl is from
the 88 the free goods from
10 years later and
telegrams inequalities in between
and what's common for all of these
uh proofs the key technique that
they used uh in the original proofs of
all these theorems
uh is the well-known hyper-contractive
inequality
um so what's
what's the idea of like
hyper-contractive inequality
and so the basic
of this using the noise operator which
smoothes the functions um
and somehow uh reduce
norms uh
in the proofs of those theorems and a
lot of
other proofs in analysis of boolean
functions
we use the some call corey
of the of the hyper-contractive which
involves with the
maximal degree of the function um
what happened is that when you take a
boolean function and apply noise
operator in it
it should it takes the uh the rate from
[Music]
large levels uh
down and
and somehow you get a function which is
close
to small degree
um in some cases but it's not of the
maximal degree so
the way to use it is to cut the
function at some degree and then we can
we get a function
of maximal degree which we know exactly
what is it
but what we lost in these functions is
that
now there are not boolean
if we have started with boolean function
and we apply noise operator and then cut
it
they're not boolean and sometimes
they're even not
bounded and
these cases are
it's hardly to use uh to get back the
results from the hyper contractivity to
say something about
the difference between norms
um so just to clarify when you apply the
noise it is bounded but when you
truncate it's not necessarily bounded
yeah um
exactly um
so anyway the use
the the exact meaning of the hyper
conductivity is
a little bit mystery and
we've wondered whether there is
life beyond the hyper-contractive
inequality
and certainly there have been
efforts to prove the kkkl terms and
strategies of it without using the hyper
contractivity
the reason is not only because it's a
mystery
and also because it's hard diaper could
actually have its limitation
uh using the maximal degree and
it's hard to get new results using
these techniques um
so what we've done is to um
to just prove the kcl theorem and
the other theorems without using the
hyper contractivity
and this is actually the rock we show
alternate proof
for existing uh um
results uh that doesn't use
this hyper contractivity and we hope
that our techniques
uh let us prove a
new statement
so what is our technique so our result
is actually a unified approach for all
of these three terms
we used the same techniques for
uh for all these three terms
and so in order to understand
what what actually is the kcl say it say
something about the structure of the
function
if the all the influences are small then
the total influence is large
um so in order to understand the
structure of function we want to make it
simpler
um so simpler functions are functions
of a lower degree for example
um less variables
so the rate to take functions
from larger degree to small degree
so one way is to use the noise operator
another way is to use random restriction
in random description we actually look
at the
sub sub cube and
that way we get maybe simpler function
which we can analyze better
and so our goal is our telling you
it now is to get to uh functions
with uh
[Music]
i i want to say um of degree one
um and we'll be very happy if we have
functions of degree one because we know
exactly what are they
they're they're only dictatorships and
this is
the easiest way to analyze something
and so we'll not get exactly there
but this is our mission
and so for that we will
use random restrictions
trying to get there and we'll see how we
do it
the other tool we need is when we get to
the functions of degree one we need to
analyze them somehow so if
if there were exactly one
we are done but they are not so we need
exactly
other tools so we'll use the logs obrev
inequality and
[Music]
so what is the log supply of inequality
i bring i bought here
some version of it this is not the
version we use but
this is the version which is the most
similar to the
hyper contractivity
so it actually looks
the same the only difference here are
the
um that the hyper contractivity use the
maximal degree
and the logs overlap use the expected
degree
okay the expected of size s is
the expected degree this is a total
influence
after normalization um
which we get if we we think about the
[Music]
fourier coefficient of the
and take every character with
probability
f s squared uh
then that this expectation is actually
the expected degree and
[Music]
so what why it's so important to use the
log superlav and not the hyper
contractivity so as we
said about the hyper contractivity it's
used the maximum degree which sometimes
we need to cut the function to in order
to use
this hyper to the hyper contractivity
and
when we take a combination of functions
um or do some induction
of a function we can take for example a
function
and partition the
characters to two disjoint sets
in some way and analyze each part
of them as a separate function
and then combine them together back
together
um then in the hyper conductivity
the maximal degree might be the maximal
the maximum of
of the maximal degrees of the
combinations of the function
involving the combination but in
locksmith
if we want to combine back
functions it's much easier if we
for example take the
a function and uh
and separate the its characters
to disjoint charts the expected
character size will be the average of
the expectations and
therefore this looks over the lobster
have give us
a stronger tool in this sense that we
can
um actually we have the additive
the additivity of the parameter
and and also we don't have to cut
functions
if we have a function which is
somehow boolean or
or bounded we know that it's still
bounded
we don't close this
yeah so it seems that the log sobolev
inequality is stronger than the hyper
contractivity right
uh because the expected size of the set
is always smaller than the degree
yes in some sense it's stronger in some
sense it's even uh
equal okay um and i'll tell you
why it's even if i i guess that you can
just
prove the locks overlap using the hyper
contractivity
um but but in when you use it
yes it's stronger and
just see that you have the norms there
so looks over have
um as far as i know uh works
exactly for these two one nodes
when the hyper contractivity um
more flexible with the norms
but when we talk about boolean functions
then it's not really matter because
all the norms all the moments are equal
so it's just up to some constant here
um okay so what we'll do in this talk
we just uh talked
we waved the hands um
um just to clarify
whether i'm understanding the inequality
right if f was boolean
this would be like the left hand side
would be the influence and then
the right hand side would be zero right
um if it's minus one one yes it will be
zero but if it's uh zero one you get
there
uh you actually get the uh edges or
parametric inequalities except the
standard one
okay you see that yeah
there was another question in the chat
they were asking what is uh the
size of the set s like what does this
notation mean
okay so our s is a is a subset of n
um i will go back to the slide of the
um just one minute
here
so we have uh the parity functions for
every s we have the party function which
is
um exactly the variables
uh in the their index indices
are in the set s um
and then we have for every character
which involved with this
s we have the fourier coefficient of
this s
and s is the size of this subset there
are subsets of
n okay you can see here in the basis we
have
s is subset of n and for each subset
and when we talk about
the total influence um you can see that
the fourier presentation of the total
influence is
the summation of all the over all the
characters the size of s
times the fourier coefficient squared so
if we see we think about the fourier
coefficient squared as
probability then we get here exactly the
expected
character size which also recalls the
expected degree because
for each size of characters this is a
some level some degree of the characters
okay and
so every boolean function defines a
probability distribution over sets
where the probability of something a set
is for a coefficient squared and
then you take the expectation with
respect to this
okay thank you for clarifying um i have
a question
and so in the definition of hyper
contractivity you have the
the denominator f in the normal three
halves and in the log sub level
of norm one is this like an important
difference or
you can say something about that
so our diaper contactivity is much more
flexible with it you can take
[Music]
every every number between one and two
and the logs overlap is
somehow as far as i know is uh
used only the norm one
again for boolean functions it's not
really matter
because all the moments are equal
and then we get there only a different
constant because it's in the log um
you can think about it as uh if you take
the hyper conductivity uh instead of
uh three over two you take two minus
epsilon
um no
then you can think about it as epsilon
[Music]
coverage to one and maybe you get
somehow the log sobolev and the
limitation
i'm not sure about the details but there
is something
like this there there is
okay thanks and so in this talk
we will prove the kkl theorem
um
and give all the techniques along the
way we'll develop
our tools i'll cheat um
anna say a little bit i'll cheat a lot
in the first hour i hope we'll have
enough time
to to fix all of these cheatings
um but if not it's also okay because
the proof idea will be a in the first
hour
uh what i mean to be the first hour i'm
not sure
if it will be um actually it will fit
the time
okay so just for a state-of-the-art what
are the other proofs that
are hyper-contractivity free
and so there is a work of
um duver ferric and
alex samardinsky from 2007
and they proved their kkl theorem and
the food good quanta theorem they also
used the
log survey inequality and not the hyper
contractivity
the difference is they they add
different uh
approach than what we do and their
uh proof doesn't seem to be extendable
uh to the telegrams inequality
another work is uh by ronald dan and
renan gross
very recent they used a very different
approach
uh which is very very interesting um
they use stochastic calculus and
analysis of jump process and dornan
talked about it
last week
anyone that missed it is welcome to see
it in the
in the website um and then our
uh our result that uh also
um parallelized to this result somehow
okay so just uh we reminder
we are going to prove the kkkl theorem
in the version that say that if all the
influences are small
then the total influence is large um
so from now on we just assume that all
the influences are small and
we'll try to prove that uh the total
inference is
large um so let's start with
random restrictions and
you just use it to
in order to simplify the function
to get a structures that are
that are easier for us to to understand
then combine all of them
together
in order to get the our result
and to get our street structure on the
function f so let's start with the
restriction which is not randomized
so what is a restriction we
uh we just
choose um there is some subset of
variables let's say f of n variables and
some variables will be free and some of
them
we will give them
some fixed value and that's how
we choose a subset of the
sub cube to look at um
so we just define j will be the alive
variables from now on the variables that
are not constant
and z
here will be the assignment for the
other variables
um which is from now for now at least
constant and then we get a new function
from the it depends on j and z that
we choose and it takes values on the sub
cube
minus 1 1 to j um
this just means values for the
variables in the set j
um say for a to r
what is the value of uh of the of this
function for any point
uh any assignment y want y k
it will take exactly the
the value of f in the same point
we just look at the sub cube and get
same values
and okay so
the uh the restriction we can
have some um for formal uh
um definitions for restrictions and
what's very interesting is
how the fourier transform of the
restriction looks like
we already know the fourier transform of
f
and let's derive the fourier transform
from
the restricted function for any
restricted function
so just a formal definition for those
that doesn't like uh
too many animations and
so let's not something before we go to
the
fourier transform and if f
is boolean valued that is
all the values of f let's say 1 0 1 or
-1 1
then every restriction is
also boolean valued function okay it's
pretty trivial we just look at
sub cubes or its same values subset of
the
of the values that f can get um
okay just to to make it clear
um let's think about an example
so if we have uh for example the address
function
which takes k plus 2 to the k
inputs where the first k
is the address they choose one of the
other variables to be their dictatorship
um it looks like this we have
k variables in total k and the k is the
first
k choose one dictatorship
um as the binary value
this is the index of the of the dictator
so if we choose a j to be
the set of two to decay variables
and uh and we fix
some address uh it's very easy now to
understand the function
the restricted function f j z it's
exactly a
dictatorship okay for every z
it will be the same
[Music]
okay so let's see the fourier
representation
um so for every uh
f restricted function f
uh we can think about it as the function
of
z and y where z is constant
so we can use the for yeah
a little bit um
okay we we can use the the four yeah the
fourier expansion of
f and just
put there both z the constant
part and y which is the three variables
and because the parity functions
are
[Music]
homomorphism that that's already called
not sure and there are keflyot
multiplicative yes this is the the
okay this is what's called okay doesn't
matter we can separate
the z on the variables
that are outside j and y on the
variables
inside j and then we get that
uh the part of z
on of the in the parity function
is actually constant now
so it's go together in the
um with the fourier coefficient
and we and we have only the part of
s that inside j um that
the intersection and of s and j they are
like variables in
s this is actually the new character
so what we have here it looks like a
four-year representation but it's not
exactly because we have every
uh it's not exactly how we used to see
it because
we have every character here might
appear
more than one time different as
different characters
s might have same intersection with j
same set of alive variables
so let's sum up all of them together
just for every uh potential character
a subset of the like variables we take
together all the characters that
have exactly those variables alive
and this is exactly the the fourier
coefficient of the subset t
and we already have this uh the
sum of presentation of this fourier
coefficient and we can see
that it's actually as a function of
z we have exactly the fourier
representation of this fourier
coefficient
so let's denote it as g t z just to make
sure that this is a function of
z and not of t or something like this
just fix some t
we have g t of z a function of
uh of z and we have the uh
the fourier representation of this
function
which is actually the part of f
of the characters that their alive
variables
are exactly the set t
so this is uh gt is a function that
grows from the sub cube
of the values outside j
um to say r okay it's not it's not
any more boolean function there's no
reason for it to be a boolean function
and you can think about it as a
table of a table of the
characters and the different
restrictions where in each
place in the in the table we have the
fourier coefficient
for the character and the appropriate z
so if we uh fix some
z some restriction and look
on the uh for the wall
we have all the fourier coefficient for
the
restricted functions with z
and if we
look on the column
we take we have some subset of j
character j and we have the different
values of it
of the fourier coefficient of it for
different
restrictions um
okay this is important and we'll uh
we'll see it again later so let's now
uh it will be interesting to think what
happened if we randomize
z for example if we choose random z
and so for now we take the random
restriction
it's exactly uh it's almost
same as before we we have the j
fixed j which is our live variables and
now we random each
value of z uniformly at random
each value is -1 with probability of one
otherwise we can get a function but now
this function
is a random function
um so we can think about it as a random
variable
we can think about other um
interesting parameters that are
randomized now
for example we can think about uh some
character
what is the expected value over z
of the fourier coefficient of this
character
so once we have the uh for your
representation of it it's
pretty easy to see that it is exactly
the empty character of the fourier
representation which is
the uh fourier coefficient of t
in f um so
we'll go for a other
more interesting parameters
this is not very interesting one
we've lost your audio
sd are you still here
maybe we should take short break because
maybe i still have some technical
difficulties so
uh let's
let's get back in say 10 minutes
let's take the break now hopefully
things